I see he brings her a good point I want
to lose weight
yeah but I don't want to lose weight you
don't lose weight man some point you
gotta be hungry Tanner and I don't like
that feeling so I'll never lose weight
you're right there is that point that is
not true okay that is not true I thought
that that's not that's not the case
no the right stuff see I'm going through
this whole body transformation deal cuz
I'm doing uh I'm doing a physique
competition you are yeah so which is
thus the meal prep ring and everything
yeah and what what I've learned
obviously changed my life and the most
important element is your nutrition yeah
but you don't have to be hungry like I
eat what do you eat like six meals a day
I've just Chia breast five meals a day
yeah of chicken rice or broccoli salmon
whatever or yeah was the last time you
had a piece of pizza I haven't I'm not
trying to guilt it I'm curious when's
the last time you had dessert I'm not a
dessert person
oh you don't worry I'm not a candy
person not a dessert person so I don't
have authority in candy would you eat
Reese's Cups teal ugh
I almost I'm a Snickers on the road and
on the golf course
he hates the Reese's they're they're
good like the initial bite and then once
you get past that are you yeah I would
just rather you hear do you hear this
man smart man right here all right so
we've already started the podcast the
air in his Greg Jennings we were talking
about food because he has a meal prep
chicken breast and broccoli if you hear
chewing it's that he's a busy man
he's a busy man now I'm starving yeah
and I want to eat like real my problem
is you mind what is this real chicken
ought to be hungry after that no you'll
feel good my problem is is I can't do
the like a nice restaurant and order
less I'm like ooh that's truffle mashed
potatoes like there's an that is a good
point yeah so you have to be a little
strategic about your plans when it comes
to I got I had some buddies here yeah
going to a premiere whatever we'll have
you there like let's go to eat and I'm
like do I eat right before do I need to
look at the menu that we're going to see
they get what I need it's just it's your
level of commitment but to the to your
weight-loss point yeah all you have to
do is be in the calorie deficient you're
right mentality take care of it so you
know but you can still eat like
consistently to where you're not hungry
gotta be disciplined too and I don't
have that like I have learned over every
day yeah but I don't know when sorry
shut up you have to understand like I I
have been around so many professional
athletes and I know one of the keys to
their success is the repetition mm-hmm
that we call somebody like Bill
Belichick boring but part of the reason
these successful is because every
Tuesday at 7:50 he knows what he's doing
right we make fun of JJ Watt for being a
little bit corny but we also go man gets
gains and the people that don't are the
people are like I'm cool Alfie exactly
but the problem is is I love life like
that like that's the flavor of life that
I like of course but I'm also knowing
that that's not how you get gains you
know it's it's bad to be aware I think
those you can but you can appreciate
what they do thousand percent this I've
had in periods where I've been able to
do it and so and in the same to be said
on their side like they have periods
where they let go like but it just looks
a little different you know Bella checks
let go is go get on the water get on the
boat right and just sit there family go
just what do you think Bell Belichick's
I've heard balichek likes to go to Bon
Jovi concerts like I heard he gets down
and he goes with like Doug Flutie and
they'll go to like grog and see Bon Jovi
really yes that's what I've heard he
does he seems like he's so buttoned up
normal football season that he has to me
you can't be buttoned up like that there
that buttoned up I get a little nervous
about how far they go and they don't
when they do we were talking about for
Greg that you had one year in Miami yeah
you played every year in these cold
places Minnesota Green Bay was cut all
this stuff and you go to Miami
can you explain to people how difficult
it is for these focused regimented
humans to be in a place that's one of
the few party cities
of NFL cities but to still focus on
their craft it's a struggle it is a
struggle it's like when you go as a head
coach you you're you're fighting two
worlds the world of we have to prepare
these guys to be competitors and ready
to play at the optimum level but then
when they leave which and you want to
respect their time as their adults
because we're like these are men yes I
don't want to treat them like kids so
then you have to concern yourself with
yeah but if I give them too much time
they'll be at live the first thing is
shoot down to Miami how different what
is it like being a professional athlete
in a city like Miami what it what is
available to you there that maybe wasn't
available in Appleton Wisconsin we're
talking real talk right Real Talk is
just the it's not even so much that
anything is different it's just you're
you're not a you're not a fish in a
fishbowl
you're just a fish swimming like in the
ocean and so nobody is really paying
attention to other fish right because
they're swimming in them enjoying the
water and the the scenery as well so you
go out and Appleton and everywhere you
go you you're noticed somebody you're
afraid that's somebody my man in Miami
everybody's trying to do the same thing
so it's like they're not even concerned
about you I'm sure I'm on my own mission
and as a professional athlete there's
something really great about that you
know about kind of being anonymous like
you're a blood see Kelly like well think
about this though just to answer your
question Philly's great Philly's good
but the one reason is hard for me to
live in Philly is because now as a
father now as a home yeah I just wants
to hang out a little bit it's hard to
let your hair down with the cameras and
you know you can't enjoy it
in fact now just think about Miami
though because as a player you don't
really get to throw three thirty four
o'clock on Saturday so you got a couple
hours before your meeting at 7:00 your
meeting from 7:00 to 9:00 so you got a
couple hours from 9:00 to 11:00 and
hopefully you make your bed check yes
you just hope that you know if you know
West Coast you may come to day before
that's the Friday now teams get in
trouble if you come on Friday because
usually when you're at home on Fridays
I'm hanging out my boys right doing
different things so as a team now you
have a reason to say well you know coach
we need a little bit later curfew and
because normally on Fridays we always
hang out as a team yeah you make up
whatever and who knows what goes on on
Friday but this is how but this how this
thing started starts before the C's you
get your schedule you say Oh tricky
Levin guess what we're at my Andy so you
call up whoever you know you're planning
three months ahead whatever you know in
Miami okay so now now let's say we use
Miami the circled city in NFL there's a
couple of Miami's one of them though I
mean now that you have LA exactly you
got LA now so LA circled City what's
like New Year is New York one of those
or no New York is tough because you're
you're so confined and if you get City
yeah if you get stuck you it you're done
what about Arizona okay San Francisco
not so much
so it's LA at Miami really well you know
what I had some fun in Seattle one time
because again pulled on those teams
going to what about Atlanta I said
Atlanta you did is minus D city right
now it's the up-and-coming city man
we're all smiling way too much fun have
we smiling because they're so I'm
excited to be here cool you're doing a
physique competition
I am I just start this is day Tory's
going for class so what classification
ster olimpio no no like that that's
that's like body building so there's
different so you got physique
competition whereas guys are in board
shorts and it's just good yeah helps you
have right rings Dom not eight I think I
got six I know but so for me I'm going
for a classic physique so it's more
bulky
but you got like five poses yeah
you gotta build your legs up you got to
look good you were you're not in the
little thong yeah but you in the little
in the lord joint the speedo is small
Jill but it's a it's a new way of
training it's literally what excites me
and why I'm so like gung ho about it
it's because I'm seeing these
transformations in my my physique yeah
that I didn't get when I was
functionally training the way that
explosion training yes yeah so it's
exciting and my gains have come from
this which is why I'm like where's my
food where's my because I'm excited
because I'm gonna look I just posted
something on Instagram and I'm not up
shirtless guy typically always in
long-sleeve shirts but I post it from
day one to day 7 and from day 7 to day
14 and your workouts were the same this
this change the diet workouts have
changed yeah more of a hypertrophy
workout now and I'm on splits but I four
days a week I'm only in there for about
an hour and so I'm looking at that like
well it's not just the gym right
it is the nutrition 3 going this is my
third week ok like in when I say I see
it so that's why I'm listening about 33%
have heard me go on so many different I
had a summer where I went vegan for a
month you would talk about cut man
I had a jawline it was great major right
back well because after a while you okay
this I'll share something my fiance will
kill me day 22
I got a Popeye's on 23rd Street and we
you know reading real vegan like we're
asking we're asking we're asking waiters
what did you cook this in right like
obnoxious vegan and we walked by a
Popeyes and I've never seen her get more
upset in my life yeah she goes I can't
even eat a [ __ ] bisque uh-huh and I
was like I know and we like broke down
and we're like 9 days left and when we
got done we had bacon in that first meal
and it was like bacon is a different
level food I like flavor
see the problem is if you're doing
something that's restricted restricting
honest
it's not psychology like if you're not
enjoying it it's not sustainable that's
in life yeah so I could like some
barbecue sauce on it
so and that's what I tell people like if
there's a meal where I'm struggling
I'll have this but give me a little
barbecue sauce yeah like I'm sharing a
suit he just spit on the mic start off
with this though I want to go right to
the cup Greg we do Wednesday cup because
we only have Westbrook for about 15 more
minutes he's got to go run the world and
take over you know I'm gonna have you
read to the cup all right but you have
to do what what voice should he do I
think you should do Aaron Rodgers start
there
do what jay-z voice you don't you have
to read it as though you're jay-z honest
I'm terrible with this you know what
everybody except for left comb give me
give me give me a starting point let me
let me hear the voice or or do a do a
West Virginia voice how much of the
legendary Greg Jennings Madden YouTube
clip can everybody recite from memory
all right I don't know if that was more
south I don't know do you know I don't
think you do know I hope you know Greg
the Madden clip that has gone super
famous it's like you're beat you're
joking I am joking
what is that clip like for you the fact
that there's a clip on the Internet of
you I'm gonna play it for West has been
revolutionary it's changed my life it's
it's it literally has made me it turned
me into a celebrity overnight no it is
actually super super cool it's a guys
playing Madden any he lived there's a
glitch in the game and I break my leg
and so he's like Oh Greg Jennings he
broke his leg but forget that he's not
saying forget that I know it has 15
million views
it's from nine years ago
in the game Greg Jennings breaks his leg
and then goes like 80 yards on a broken
leg but it's like commentary that kind
of takes it and so he has a broken leg
[Music]
[Laughter]
Oh Darren Sharper one of the hardest
hitting safeties in the league
oh but it don't matter I'll put the team
on my back though touchdown great dude
it's up there like in the internet there
are different like characters in
internet like that's a video but Greg
Jennings putting the team on his back so
how often do people like say that to the
time really all the time
dude I taped Greg Jennings into YouTube
and the first I thought that was great
Jennings broken leg yep
I literally used to get people and it
still happens periodically people asking
me like remember when you people who
really don't know remember when you
broke your leg right and you put the
team on your back and I'm like yeah man
that was cool and I played through
anything I don't do anything player I am
Wow in a weird way a Madden clip is
going to get morphed into real life for
some people and eventually people will
not be able to tell the two apart and I
it could be an NFL Films on the frozen
tundra of Lambeau Field Greg Jennings
put the team on his back though that was
good I can get better I believe you
can't I mean you justify if I smoked a
Daddy cigar I turn into Batman like it's
really weird like I've hung out with
friends I've been like yo meal was good
man and they're like why did your voice
get like that is
that's how it goes yeah if the night
goes on get into the cup Westbrook you
will do do you do a good Sylvester
Stallone no I don't do any of these no
you do I love it Shannon Sharpe yes give
me something from Shaymin let me see
come on skill skill skill we wouldn't
say see use are we doing it say we got
the hand oh we got the black we got hey
LeBron
LeBron JEA come on skill all right now
ski up there it is
nice left I was going to get married
next year skip you understand me now
listen what's the best wedding or
marriage advice you can offer to him
yeah it's good hate it it was good
Shannon no I don't think was good all
right so I'm gonna marry next year yep
what advice do you have if you'd only to
give one piece of advice and so all the
other homies out there that are
listening they're getting married to do
it damn don't be that guy yeah don't be
that guy don't be that I got I had that
guy at my wedding
I'm dead serious before I come out hey
you know you don't have to go through
this really really if you're really not
ready
Wow I already spent all this money now
I'm not gonna lie I have been at a
wedding where I did not think that they
were made for each other
I actually one time got disinvited from
a wedding because I spoke my truth
really yeah yeah I had a roommate how
long really quick how long have you been
with your two years two years oh we know
you guys live well together
yeah she makes she makes me a better
person the advice man don't ever try to
change her mmm
don't ever try to change oh no I haven't
tried to help her change me in in
Annette's but but who you are is what
she's what she's drawn to yeah what she
loves and so I think in marriages we get
to the point where we're trying to
perfect our mate and it's like I wish
you did this I wish it because we see
others that we or we have other
experiences to be fully transparent
where you kind of want and it's like no
but
something obviously that you do
separates you other every other guy and
something that she does separates her
don't ever try to change that that was a
good one
all right Brian step it up so be a good
big bro yeah this is something that that
you don't act when you're younger you
with a woman and she does something
wrong whatever it is you're like get out
of here you're on to the next one right
the key for me was that when you get
married I'm pretty even when you get
engaged it's we're arguing but we're not
arguing so we're breaking up
we're arguing so we're better in each
other right so we're not it's a big
difference because most the time you
argue just want to win even though
you're married now you're argument
because now I'm not just trying to get
my point across I'm trying to get you to
understand where I'm coming from
right so I want us to be better at him
and at the end we ain't going nowhere no
matter what you say no matter what I say
we ain't going to where it is we want to
argue in that manner because if you
argue saying some things that go the
other way then there ain't gonna work
you gotta ask you in a reasonable manner
I have always been the guy in
relationships that women will get
frustrated with because they'll get
angry and anger and then all of a sudden
I get really calm mm-hmm and then I'm
like I don't know why you're talking
that loudly and it's like so I'm really
good at going oh this is getting
dangerous I'll pull that ripcord real
quick i don't even argue no i don't
argue i'd never true story or fact my
pen ever I have three other siblings
I'm two of four my older sister is 37 my
youngest sibling my brother is 35 we've
never heard our parents raise their
voice or argue that was one thing I
wanted to take into my mirrors so my
kids have never heard my daddy raise
their voice or argue when that when we
say when we're disagreeing and I'm
looking at it like babe really mm what
are you talking about they are looking
with eyes like deer in headlights like
wow my son's like he came and checked on
me like couple weeks ago daddy are you
mad and I was like no man did I did I
sound mad he was like no and mommy ma no
mommy argues mommy argues I was like did
you
ask mommy no why did you come back to me
man I don't know because you scared axe
mom yes I'm like yeah good daddy I don't
argue but it's a strength that I have
that I don't try to get her to not argue
yeah but I'm not gonna I'm not gonna do
what I don't do you know what was weird
because I'm thinking about my wife and
one thing that she does and I absolutely
despise and I've had to kind of learn to
live careful is she maybe August she
knows this already when we argue and we
it gets to a point she's like I'm out
I just I'm done with the conversation
and I'm like nah so yeah I gotta finish
this thought in that I do it though she
needs time yeah and that time is foreign
to me yeah it's good for her I might
take some time I'll write some stuff
down I need to cuz my thing is is like I
like to be quick and so the thing I like
to win and so if I see it's going down
I'd be like or you mean like give me
like two days ago but have you ever been
the good friend that's kind of told
somebody the truth that no one else has
told them like I had a roommate that him
and his girl would fight every day and
they got engaged and I pulled him aside
one time I said listen man I said you're
about to live a life that you don't want
to live I said all you do is complain
and then any and he's like yeah I think
you're right I think you're right and
all of a sudden like I moved and I
didn't get invited and they got divorced
six months in and yeah you try because I
have been the guy that I looked around
my friends and said why didn't you tell
him yeah yeah I don't want that yeah cuz
I had though I had one of those
relationship you know my friend says I'm
always like man I don't want to tell
them exactly that I want to convert I
hate man you said you want to be happy
you don't seem happy now like I want to
chew the scene are you can't at it every
since she's come around you are not
happy I don't know what it is I prefer
your approach and I typically take your
approach and I love when I hear people
that take your approach yeah because you
know without doubt that's an authentic
that's a real yes
you know what I'm a good I may not agree
with it I may not like these don't tell
her I said that exactly is then you're
gonna make it weird you know I know that
I'm on your team
but you when you get people like that
those are the realest because I'll never
forget I ended one and then I went to my
friends as I know I ended my own a long
time and I went to my friends are like
oh thank God we didn't like her and I
was like you could have said something
he's like oh everybody felt that way
and I was like what and after I felt
that I was like never again yeah I was
like I want to be a good do for you yeah
for you I'm gonna cut what voice should
I do
man I feel like you're pretty talented
you know I always end up doing Mike
Tyson no I just have a list that Ingmar
sent me what are you say one of them is
the voice people do when they are
talking to a baby hey let's do it if
people talk to my baby in a baby voice
they will happen I am the dude that goes
and talks to dogs like an adult like
I'll be like what up dog and then the
owner ID so I was I was talking to the
dog I just thought a baby talk here Doug
Mick wouldn't seen the specific
prediction of something that would have
been in the playoffs comes true you look
like a genius
all right so make a prediction of
something that's gonna happen in the
playoffs but it's got to be very
specific so if it comes true we will
save this clip and we'll put it on
bleacher report and be like wow
Greg Jennings was incredible or Wow
Brian Westbrook is a fortune teller so
and we and if it doesn't come true
nobody cares it's the media oh I know
let you go first go for it the Minnesota
Vikings Minnesota Vikings will be in the
Super Bowl Wow
got a good defense the football Kirk
Cousins for some reason has learned how
to win important football games they'll
be in a Super Bowl Wow
this year okay I'm gonna go really
specific specific is that not specific
enough it was pretty good I think
specific is you being like Stefan Zweig
catches the game-winning touchdown I'll
rewrite the rules
okay I mean that's what he said yeah
thanks and I like those rules
I played by my old room yeah let's work
smarter all right so I'm gonna go with
the team that I know is gonna be in the
playoffs oh this will happen
mmm you know what I'm gonna go to
Lambeau and I'm gonna say Aaron Rodgers
will throw for three touchdowns and in
the last drive he won't win the game for
him but he'll get them in field goal
position I don't care about who was
against in Mason Crosby we'll miss the
field goal and they'll lose the game and
they'll lose that's very specific and
everybody in Green Bay he's gonna hurt
you ain't you now it won't get played
until we're safe in Green Bay exactly
yeah it'll be okay they already hate me
earning a journey well they don't really
technically hate me they just don't like
that they don't like the truth yeah they
don't want it you've been talking about
we're gonna get into this they don't
like truth about quarterback look I
don't I praise him I kind of feel but I
also I'm not gonna lie when you started
that story with Aaron Rodgers like hmm
I'm gonna say that the New England
Patriots are going to go into Baltimore
and they're gonna use a trick play in
which Mohamed Sanu throws a touchdown to
Edelman to knock off Lamar Jackson and
advanced in the playoffs which means
that the Baltimore Ravens have
home-field advantage
is all right let's talk about Aaron's
all right let's do it
do you need to go right now all right do
you and do one more Cup yes okay one
more Cup Duke Elias Campbell he sounds
like if the Cookie Monster baritone who
do you want to play you in this worth
movie about your life and your career
tell me right now Harry yeah all right
so if there was a movie made about you
who would you want to play you in a
movie uh and if you say Denzel that's
okay no I'm gonna say Jamie Foxx hmm
uber talented can do any and everything
I would love to see him play me
pretty good what did you say jamie foxx
okay who is your star of pride the rock
yeah man you're more like a Kevin Hart
told me a few weeks who is five ten is
Kevin Hart five to be sure like five
three yeah that's why I know I'm five
ten yeah but you you said the rock
coming this fall the rock is Brian
Westbrook it's gotta be a little
realistic oh the rock is a realistic not
for you bro Jamie Jamie and I are
similar in stature complexion yeah I
still have here even a hairline that up
front but I mean me Fox's hair job is
one of the greatest of all time I'm just
telling you right now that if you google
Jamie Foxx hairline there are some
photos that I didn't know exist yet he
went up in a box and I'll say this we've
reached a point do whatever the [ __ ] you
want yeah it's a really care but that
thing was wild and I go Jamie Foxx's
career could have come to an end if he
didn't fix that like look we live in a
world in which jay-z wore a bandana for
eight months I wonder why yeah and now
all of a sudden he's got that Jimmy
Butler haircut like LeBron James it's
caca bout it yeah yeah I could see like
David Schwimmer playing me the dude from
Ross from friends that's a good one but
who do I want to play me you know I
would want someone that's like naturally
kind of cool
I don't know white people all look alike
Bradley Cooper
that would be great one cool about
yourself someone that's naturally cool
I would want to play my own self David
if you think of any good once and to my
ear I it wasn't good was good I was more
excited that you said the rock yeah I
was like I want to hone it on that
People's Champ the robber all right
Colin Hanks Tom Hanks the son I take
that as an insult
have you seen him before I would want
Jack Black to play me in a movie Jack
Black with yeah super cool super cool
round yeah yeah all right for Brian
Westbrook a Rocket Man we'll see you
later pal all right
I'll let you up maybe we'll do something
tomorrow okay I'll hit you up maybe
we'll do something more are you in town
no I'll be gone we'll actually do some
tomorrow show they'll be on first things
first tomorrow have my buddy Nick right
you know um I said hi I will
yeah I gotta watch basketball through
soon we're doing that we're doing
Westbrook's exit life it's good see you
pal
all right let's do it let's let's do one
more cup and then we're gonna get into
your hate of Aaron Rodgers and there's
no hate and if you guys back there would
have changed the cameras should we move
Greg over yeah Greg why don't you come
over here all right I'm gonna come over
we'll do it all live
I'll read it though all right I'm gonna
do it in Sylvester Stallone voice Adrian
complete this joke Greg Jennings Adam
look guys the worst celestron Greg
Jennings Adam left Cole and Brian
Westbrook walk into a bar
damn I really wanted this with Westbrook
because we've noticed a trend that
whenever talks about bars
he's like am i single yeah are you were
you a partier no ever
you never did you ever have a stage you
can grab your food if you want stage
like we did greg jennings have a
partying stage no wow you ever like do
you ever have FOMO or do you ever look
back and be like what would happen if I
really tore it up during that time of my
life um I've had those thoughts before
but it was not it just I was always the
the guy that I needed everything to be
in a controlled environment
can tell I can tell by the way you dress
the way that you eat you are a very much
like you have a little OCD a little bit
do you do like do your clothes more of
an excellent spirit I don't roll my
clothes because I don't think I get more
space that way mm-hmm but I lay them
flat so I only fold them once what is
the thing that you do that your wife
believes is the most control freakish
still I've tried to let it go
I've tried to let a lot of things go I
think when I'm coming home from either
here or LA or in travel things she's
concerned about a comment that is going
to be made about how the car is
presented mmm well when you're picked up
when I'm picked up in it and it's not
even so or the fact that like she's on
the outside already on the outside or it
just looks a mess on the inside or if
you know that I'm getting in the car and
there's a bunch of stuff right in the in
the taxi it's like I mean babe you I'm
just looking like everything from like
the way you dress to your facial hair
you're well put together and I'm singing
away I'm like I bet sometimes and I go
what day is today
like someone said to me today they're
like you really kind of just you wake up
and you just kind of go yeah I get I get
thanked all the time by the stewardess
on planes or Campbell and like wipe down
the whole seat pretty much but like my
towels in the bathroom I got put them
all on top of each other roll them up
sit them in the tub or in the in the
shower so that they don't nobody wants
to go in the bathroom and have to pick
up your I get it your washcloths but at
the same point I've never been in a
situation where I can throw things
around and then I come back and they're
fixed and I'm paying for that but I
guess we look at race like I'm kind of
like this is the one time where I can
leave a washcloth in the shower and a
towel on the bed and I don't have to get
yelled at for it
yeah in the marbre and you're helping me
because I even put that pressure on my
wife when we Wow you're helping me
in what way because when we go to then
we go to the hotel she's thinking I
already have to do this that Hong I know
this is her time to be phrase is my time
to just leave the towel on the floor
just don't get it I leave my paper on
the on the seat and it's okay and they
don't stack up all right so you
definitely in your early stages right
now and kind of transitioning to the
media world
I feel like whether it's because coward
always brings you on to talk about it
everybody wants to lean into this Rogers
thing you are in a space right now in
which I have said for the longest time
that era Rogers the best quarterback
I've ever seen I believe that there are
agreed where he is in the in a select
few people of arms him Elway mahomes
that there's just people aren't capable
of doing what he's capable of doing so
we'll establish that you agree with that
100% there is also this interesting
thing because you played a little bit
with Favre too and I think part of what
has to find Erin is he's not Brett
by the way Greg just folded up the
papers oh my goodness he couldn't even
handle it he had to fold that up and
organize it and then he just messed it
up and now he's gonna get weirded out
that it's messed up okay just so you
know but that's interesting because it's
good to know that you're like that
you're very
p's and q's organized was Erin like that
um and what is it like to be known as
the the Aaron Rodgers hater let's start
there actually let's start there yeah
what is it like for you it's you know
it's it's is disappointing honestly
because I'm not an ear modulator okay I
absolutely I absolutely would love
nothing more than to be in a private
room just he and I know camera I don't
need anybody to know yeah and let's talk
it out bro like that was my guy like and
so the what kind of triggered all of
this is I ended up telling sharing the
story about
you know the first game of the season
and him telling Carlos Rogers during the
timeout you guys should get them at when
he's playing right 49ers and that just
didn't sit well with me because this was
my guy now he's going on since then
after me telling that and says he was
joking uh I'm in a contract here like I
don't you yeah I didn't take that that
was that wasn't a joking matter like
yeah
you never said no I'm just playing like
you never I don't know
so stuck with you it did in more more
than what I ever imagined that it could
in would because I went through the
season I was injured in and out that
year so I couldn't really perform and
it's like out of all years I'm I'm now
being labeled as injured injury bone
right and I'm getting older and I've
never been really injured [ __ ] turns so
it turns so and so quick and so all of
these feelings and emotions kind of were
within and I kind of suppressed them for
the entire year I suppressed them let's
get through the year yeah I'm gonna get
this contract I want to be in Green Bay
yeah but I understand the landscape of
where we are in the history that has
gone before me history and the writing
that has always been on the wall you get
to year 7 and we would love for you to
stay but we're gonna need a discounted
rate or we're gonna need a extreme
discounted rate and we could go and get
more value and build those that contract
for next fight exactly yeah because we
have a guy like Aaron Rodgers right um
but getting to like me leaving and
talking about leadership skills and all
of that all of what I said I stand
behind because that was my experience
and that was so fact I think my the
reason that it was weird I feel like I
and with sim as before too we always
kind of felt like we had to defend Aaron
Rodgers because we always looked at NFL
from a scheme perspective because I
believe that coaches have the most
impact in this sport compared to any
other sport and there's a reason why
Belichick can take a Mac Matt Cassel and
still do what he can do and Kyle
Shanahan can
do it with Matt Schaub in Houston and
rg3 in Washington and Cleveland he did
it and that scheme is really great but I
would i we would look at Aaron
I never thought McCarthy scheme was good
and I always felt like Aaron had to
overcome the scheme and so a little bit
like how when the offensive line isn't
protecting well or that the Y receivers
aren't getting separation you start to
anticipate a rush when it's not there or
the Y receivers aren't open so sometimes
you look past that first read because it
hasn't gotten open
I always felt the need to defend Aaron
because all I saw was slant flat and it
was always Aaron being like the plays
breaking down you go that way
I'm gonna sling it from my hip 35 yards
but then we're still gonna blame Aaron
for when people don't get open so I
always felt very defensive of Aaron and
I I think I heard your story and from a
human element I went I can understand
what that would [ __ ] me up like it would
be in the back of my head at all times
being like there's truth to all jokes
mm-hmm and so you are cool with me
leaving and in this NFL world where
careers can be you're on the top of a
mountain - oh you're 30 now yeah listen
we get this guy I get it so I've always
understood it from your perspective and
I guess I'm sensitive to Aaron's family
situation I you know I have stuff in my
own family where I can kind of go may
have families tricky and so it's this
notion that I think people kind of go he
doesn't talk to his family which means
he's not a good leader which means he's
a piece of [ __ ] oh he's a good
quarterback but he's also and I've
always been like that is not indicative
of you of as a human and that's why I
always was like I think I kind of stand
for for Aaron alone that was like stop
coming after this dude and so let me
touch on the family point that you just
made out of any and everything I've ever
said about in here I've never never I've
never ever touched anything outside of
the walls and parameters of football
yeah yeah that is a no-fly zone because
people go there and I think that's
completely out of bounds yes
and so I know Aaron personally he was
one of I don't have a
a lot of people over to my home I don't
expose my children to a lot of people or
that's never been my thing
Aaron was one of those guys before
before everything and so when all of
that transpired or was falling out it
was like out of all people like that's
how you really feel this this is me
going in my own head and in some of it I
may have blown up more than what I could
have to myself and someone say well why
didn't you talk to Aaron well I
I reached out about when I was leaving
or looking at other teams I remember I
literally have like the text messages of
when we stopped when it was like dude
you can't leave he's like dude you can't
leave I was like well I mean I don't
want to leave and it was a something for
it was kind of like that was the end of
everything
yeah and I felt like if there was anyone
who could have had my back it was my guy
yeah and I felt like he didn't do that
and I felt like if roles were reversed I
would have had his back
yeah like even if I get it even if we're
not the decision-makers but just to know
you said something on my behalf right
that goes and that means a lot to me
yeah and so my my approach with Aaron
was I'm just gonna be real I'm gonna be
honest so one thing I've always said and
will continue to say he's the best he's
the best quarterback that I've ever seen
throw the ball he's one of those guys
that if I were starting a team a
franchise I would go Aaron Rodgers I
said if I would if I were playing on
that team I would go Bret because and
here's why yeah this is a testament to
his greatness there are two of the top
six quarterbacks of all time but here
listen to the reason why and people are
like oh he's only saying Bret because
and I'm like that listen to my why
because Aaron was so perfect with his
ball placement right he eliminated my
and others ability to be special hmm
like Harvard lob it up and say go get it
Aaron would hit this like low Hummer
that would rise it's like you didn't
have to do anything I literally remember
going from a guy who would attack the
ball in the air go get it to a guy that
just had to just do his job get open get
get separation and catch the football
and it was like he made it so much
easier he took away those wow elements
for us to make and he just did it with
his arm and a song sets up such a wild
concept I mean it's kind of like playing
with like a really good point guard you
know I mean where instead of getting ISO
ball you're getting nice dish to the
light and and it makes it look like
anybody came in exactly and that's where
it's like anyway say after you it did
become kind of like a rotational thing
other than Jordy of the other wide
receivers that would kind of and then it
went like a Jordy Randall Cobb situation
huh that's interesting that thought of
it like yeah so I mean in in so when I
look at the whole Aaron right people
like man you're always I remember Max
Kellerman saying I had an axe to grind I
just I was like I literally remember
picking up the phone texting Stephen a
like hey I got to come on the show and
defend my defend myself because I wasn't
trying to pick on Aaron at all but I was
stating fact in my own truth but it was
coming from a place of bitterness mmm
like I'm I'm mature enough to say that
and I've said this in years past now but
that's where it and when I had when I
reflect back on it all of what I said
was was fact and truth right but the way
that I said it mmm it was not Greg so
how did you process that because like me
and West have had talks about like his
former teammates that clearly still have
a little bit of chip on their shoulder
and I've kind of said that the only way
that I've ever been able to get over
anger is to pray for people I am NOT a
very religious person but I am somebody
that when I find myself getting into a
heated argument if I then try to put
myself into their shoes and I try and
wish them well it dissipates for me how
did you because it looks like you've
kind of gotten past it
I've definitely gotten past it but one
thing I feel like I still will always
have this part of me is that what if no
it's it's not a what if it's I know what
I said and I know Aaron and I don't even
like calling him sensitive anymore we we
know what he is but when I said when I
say in speak of him as being sensitive
right now I'm talking about
just as humanistic he's he's just a
sensitive guy he he's mindful of
everything and what everybody says he
takes it into account and he will pull
it if he has a he has a recall like a
bank yes like a bank vault like I can
roll it back
I have metal every corner of X that are
very sensitive like in its it's a lot of
them and so for me like all I want five
minutes all I want and I don't want it
for TV you know I don't want it for game
announcer I don't I just want him to
know because I know if I get him in a
room he knows me well enough to where
he's gonna say Greg why did you why
would you and I would tell him dude that
hurt I don't want to I don't want to
tell everybody else I wanted to tell you
I reached out to you I came to Green Bay
you didn't even acknowledge me I told
Mike can I get half time with Aaron you
didn't acknowledge it I told flee I told
the whole training staff tell Aaron I
want to link up with them behind closed
never acknowledged it and it's because
you love them yes I died the saying like
it's not out of haters hello check this
part out check this part out man I
appreciate this because this isn't it
feels it feels good yeah so so like I
was in I'm very good friends with the
assistant general manager of the
Milwaukee Bucks okay so I go to a game
to Aaron's like part owner exactly so
they make the playoffs last year we go
to support my pastor and I go to support
and I get there and I'm with the general
manager I'm on the floor where whatever
and I'm meeting all these I'm well guys
that I know whatever and I'm talking to
Steve Smith NBA guys Asian guy was
talking spend in one of the reporters
from Green Bay or the Milwaukee area
that comes up him Greg and I'm like I
was a little I was a little apprehensive
of being there because I didn't know how
the reception sure so I was trying to
kind of fly under the radar if I could
do that and the reception was warm from
fans everything like anyone ivory I
interacted with was great and so he said
you know Aaron's gonna be here
immediately in my head what what him
went was not like oh man it was like
this is my opportunity so I was looking
for him to get that moment of where we
could kind of sneak off so national
anthem kid you not I'm standing in the
not the tunnel but like where the sweets
or whatever food I'm standing there and
national anthem was standing and I look
and I'm there he is I literally had my
pastor next to me and I said oh there is
and now the national anthem is being
played and I can't even focus on
national anthem because I don't want my
eyes to lose him right and he's that
he's at his seat on the floor literally
in the hall mother but I'm gone
went straight straight to him I didn't
walk on the floor because I didn't want
everybody to be able to see it right so
I went behind the two benches the two
rows that were behind him reached over
tapped him on the shoulder he turns
around and says what are you doing here
and I'm I mean and I get it totally he
was in defense mechanism that's one you
know I tapped him on the shoulder he
sees it's me there's there's thirty
thousand people there he naturally and
so I said the same thing you're doing
here I'm here to watch the game he's
like you need to stop talking about me
and I'm sharing this I'm not sharing
this to create a store son he's like you
need to stop talking about me I'm like
dude I just want to talk like well let's
talk I tried to call you I tried he says
my number hasn't changed in my heart I'm
like come on man yeah I'm like what do
you I said my number hasn't changed I
pull out my phone right there at
you know I I said I'd look at my phone
and I say okay if your number hasn't
changed I pulled his number up you
called him right in front of him I did
not call him because I didn't want to do
that but I said I just sent you a text
my number hasn't changed if let's talk
man
I just just you and me yeah and that was
it and I felt I went to that game
wanting to enjoy a game oh and you
couldn't think about it and all I could
think about was men I just really want
it wasn't even that yeah I just really
wanted him to be able to give me that
time so that mask that he had to present
himself with was unveiled he could take
that off and we can just be real cuz I'm
going to be honest he I've always been
that yeah it mean and I'm honest now
saying and I've said it in the past when
I did go off on a tangent and say the
things that I said it was a little
better it was out of bitterness I was
hurt yeah like I was hurt I wanted to be
there it didn't work out I felt like you
didn't stick up for me the whole story
of what I told happened all these things
and it's like okay I was wrong I
admittedly said I was wrong I even told
him that the first time I ever played
him when I was in the Viking uniform but
it was on the field it's like in force
you know what I mean it's kind of in
disingenuous interactions are like four
or five seconds exactly and so it was
like I but I knew I knew because of
knowing who he is and how he is I got to
get him one-on-one and I think if I'm
gonna like psychoanalyze this from the
outside having never even met Aaron and
I would love to talk to Aaron I just I
wouldn't even have a real I would want
to not even think about Aaron is I don't
want to do it on camera because I feel
like he's had to protect himself
yeah and that it's true guarded and I
get it because being the quarterback for
the for the Packers is like being the
shortstop for the Yankees it's like
being the quarterback for the Cowboys
where you are almost the head of state
there is an entire state that is
obsessed with you and he followed in the
footsteps of Favre
he was booed on giraffe day we see all
the quarter of our first day of training
camp all the time because he was
replaced in the great Brett Favre his
issues with his own
I totally understand and of all the
stories where it seems like people
always want something from him
and what's interesting is is
unfortunately I figure just got to
[ __ ] wait cuz I don't think Aaron's
gonna let people in until he's been
retired for a few years
because I think he's one of those guys I
look at like the Popovich's and the
Duncans that like the Morgan Freeman's
he's probably gonna go to Wyoming we're
not gonna hear from him mmm like he's he
seems like somebody that once space and
he wants solitude and he once we only
once he wants nothing exactly I just
want to be able to kick my heels up and
just let go and and I think with Aaron
it's it's I wouldn't be surprised
this would be my wildly specific
prediction that four or five years after
he's retired you might get a random ass
text and it might be like what I hang
out like that's because I think right
now I think it's gonna be a lot better
with with this season and the joy that's
gonna come with this season and how he
finally has some support with the
defense and he's got a young coach that
goes what do you want to do and a
defense that's sort of like we got your
back and I think for a long time I think
Aaron kind of felt isolated like that's
just me reading from the outside and it
is tough because you're also in a
position where you're starting a career
mm-hmm and a broadcasting career they
want you to be honest and also I know
how this works you say a little bit of
thing about Aaron and then every place
goes hey let's book Greg Jennings
because he's apparently gonna say these
things about Aaron Rodgers and the
clicks right now are wild and our
ratings are going out actually and then
there's probably a little bit of you
that's like I need to show that I can be
because everybody's trying to be the
next Strahan everybody but and and so we
go oh people want to have me on and we
feed into that a little bit I'm sure you
did a little bit too yeah to a degree
but I'm not no like I'm not that guy I'm
just gonna be I'm not that guy so we're
not like I even looked on social today
and saw all the clickbait about me
saying that the nobody is afraid to play
the Patriots and I'm thinking what yeah
like are you kidding I'm just stating
what's true like you
teams are no longer like fearful of the
New England Patriots yeah it's just like
look no we got them teams have the
psychology of dude I'm better not the
first at the Super Bowl when they lost
to the Eagles I'm talking to I talked
like five different guys including
Melvin Ingram all these really great
players and they said the we are better
than the Patriots they just have better
coaches and are more prepared the
Patriots have been less athletic than
their opponents all the time but that's
why they're great mm-hmm because it
doesn't come down to that exact it's not
about who pushes harder and who can
throw the ball we're a better team than
exactly so that's not new but look I the
internet sucks a lot
I came out and said I think dak is the
sixth best quarterback in the NFL which
means I have Brady and Brees below him
and it's as if I'm saying that he's a
better career and he's not a
hall-of-famer and the true thing is is
just realize it other people are really
[ __ ] dumb and like we're talking
about right now yes where they are what
present day presents to all of us dak is
here that's just beyond it yes yeah I
know with you and so you know it's the
old jay-z line and it's the Drake line
it's like you don't argue with fools
because from afar you'd look the same
yeah it's definitely not the quote but
that's the Internet but the thing is
it's tough it's like will that get back
to a Patriots player and they're only
gonna see the headline and they go Greg
Jennings just a hater
that's the annoying part about this
industry exactly and so I was I was
saying this to someone the day I think
was Brandon Flowers today actually who
wants to go down this road of
broadcasting and he speaks very well on
camera and I'm telling them like the
hard part is when you're up there with
another player when you're on set with
another player you can just the
relatability is just different and so
you can talk different yes so when
you're when you're there with someone
who didn't play and they're more of an
analyst and statistically driven
individual and everything is like from
analytics perspective the conversation
is
little different and so your delivery is
going to be a little different and so
everything that you say now is like oh
man you hate but it's a transaction but
but the viewers they want you to tell
like producers and everyday want you to
tell stories about when you play it and
all that and bring it and bring it all
together in your mind you've been in a
locker room and you've looked up at the
TV and you hear the guys saying when I
played and then you'd immersing dude
you're not playing anymore
get over it like that's the kind of the
mentality in the locker room but then
when you don't go to that point then
you're trying to be the statistical X's
and O's guy that's it it's like dude
it's it's a hard it's a slope that you
you're gonna slip off one way or the
other and it I just try to be me I just
try to tell truth and give information
I'm not trying to I don't I have a
really good relationship with Tom Brady
yeah I don't want I don't have a Julian
Edelman relationship with Tom Brady but
if Tom and I saw each other we would
speak and greet each other and it'd be
like Oh tom was I'm not saying tom is
washed up I'm not trying to say New
England Patriots cultures no I'm not
orogeny the same way I'm just speaking
truth I for the same things that you
said about him as far as his excellence
I'm not rushing I don't know none but
the moment I didn't say Aaron Rodgers is
great then is because I said the
negative things after I've always said
he's great it's oh now he's no he wants
to kiss his buddy no it's not that it's
just I've always been real that
relationship of two people on camera
when it's a host like myself traditional
host non football player and football
player it gets very transactional
because every time the guy is asking you
a question he's thinking in his head
give me a soundbite that's gonna break
the Internet today and it's constant
setups it's constant kind of being like
you know if you if you had to kill one
of your teammates everything like it
would kill a guy like kill ya oh but I
got him to say and it is weird I would
say my advice to people especially
athletes training into the business is
don't just answer the question right
away like there's something about TV
of using silence and it's weird coming
from someone that talks all the time but
at any time I've seen someone they kind
of go in there or they go well and like
that [ __ ] pause like this is you're
eight minutes yep to go on television
don't [ __ ] go through and make the
producers job easy don't go through and
and have the host go hey man I was
really good all that [ __ ] take over
the segment you have limited time [ __ ]
everybody like it's not worth it like
you have it's like a tryout for a team
mm-hmm you know maybe you can go out
with that one with two hands but [ __ ] if
you come down with one hands and that
tryout they may be like yo did you see
that [ __ ] catching the cryogenics so
like like there are certain guys that
kind of go on there and take over a
studio and we're all capable of that you
just need to go in there with that
[ __ ] mindset because I think a lot of
people go on TV and they want to go that
was clean I didn't [ __ ] up I got those
three facts in nobody cares about your
facts yep nobody cares if you know what
DVO a is so if you're an athlete [ __ ]
shake their brain walk in there and be
like you know it's a funny story and
then go and they're gonna be like wow
like that's interesting television I
just you there's a lot of producers and
I love my producers and and Ingmar is
amazing but a lot of traditional
television producers that are like get
in get out and we move on and they're
not thinking about you they're just not
but yeah it's your truth has been used
against you in a few exactly and so I'm
coming to grips with that but I'm also
knowing how to counter it and what I
mean by that is I'm not trying to
backpedal but I want to I always have to
say I want to be clear about this yes
like that's a good line I want to be
clear about this yeah I am NOT saying
that's what I think of a lot of you
clear about that I'm going to look right
into that camera I'm gonna look right
into that camera yeah it's alright
that's that's kind of my line of okay
I'm about to say something but that
could be taken out of context in very
well
yes we'll be taken out of context but
that's not why I'm saying it yes I'm
about let me so let me be clear and then
I'll preface something and then say what
I want to say to talk about Aaron really
quick as you're watching this packers
team and you're watching his mannerisms
and the way he's reacting does it look
at all different to you this season
compared to years past and what looks
different to you so it does and I was
talking to one of my buddies just when
you talk to your buddies you tell him
Harry of course and so I was telling him
I'm like dude is scary because the one
thing that everyone thought would be
real this or blow up this entire deal
including myself was Aaron Rodgers and
his ability to just embrace the new
coach right he's done it I know he's
done everything that we put in the media
was saying if he does it or if he
doesn't it would send the Packers
sailing right or they would sink that
was the off season storyline he'll he
listened to a coach around his age
Methos not have a lot of success in this
league and give up calling plays the
line of scrimmage running a two-minute
drill and we've seen it and I think
what's beautiful about it is he's not
had to give up what we all thought he
would have to give up like he's not
gonna be able to call but he's still
controlling and calling plays making a
transformer but he's skirts in the
beginning let him do the end of games
and a half's but he's calling the plays
that he enjoys he likes so it's and
everything is like he understands like
the cameras gonna always be on me so
anything that I do anything I say it's
gonna be taken out of context yeah so if
I look at if I look upset which I am I'm
playing football everything isn't gonna
be great it's like yeah I see the way he
looked or if he does anything and he's
excited it's like oh he's smiling now
look he's always smiled he's always
gotten obsessed like it's just it's just
taken we isolated in this fine glass for
this moment and say man that's what I
hate when we talk about Odell we see
Odell on the side
and he looks angry and it's like Odell
is clearly frustrated and it's one he
should be he's yeah thing don't you want
your athletes to be frustrated I was an
Eagles fan they would get upset at
Donovan for smiling during losses we
love to do that with our athletes that
you can't win no the only way you can
win is if you win yeah because if you
win it doesn't matter don't matter when
we do you can be Grunk and you can do
whatever and you can get in trouble and
it's fine because you're winning and
you're crunk but if you lose it's all
your from hmm absolutely do you think
them Saints Niners Seahawks maybe
Cowboys feels like the four teams in the
NFC how good of a chance do you think
they have I don't have the Vikings in
there the Packers I just don't
I like the Vikings I do yeah I'd look
like a really good T no losing the
divisional right yeah I the Packers to
me are the scariest of all the teams
okay and the reason why I say that is we
know what Aaron is right and if that
defense plays anywhere close to what
we've seen them play on a good day right
they're not they're not gonna lose right
because the Seahawks defense we've
actually seen Russell have to put on the
Cape almost every game this year
the Niners I've been very impressed with
their ability to continue winning
without Kittel and those guys but we see
the limitations of the quarterback
position in crunch time exactly the
Saints if they're not in the dome in
January I don't care Brees isn't doing
it it's all Michael Thomas it's all
alvin kamara
now again if it's in the dome go home be
a completely different team but Aaron we
haven't seen him have to go crazy Aaron
do many times it's literally been he's
saving it it's literally so the Eagles
game was probably the only game that he
went crazy and it was like man this is
vintage Aaron well he has that's what
makes them so scary us he can do that
yeah but he hasn't had the need to
because everybody like them and having
Aaron's like Aaron Jones in the
year that he is having catching the ball
out of the backfield and running between
the tackles yeah and his ability to
break the big play in long run it has
changed the landscape and the dynamic of
that often and it's so funny too cuz
like look I'm sure McCarthy is a great
guy but I have to be wondering that all
last year really the last two years
everyone has said why don't you throw to
your running backs why don't you throw
to Aaron Jones and it was always like oh
we try and now we see how prolific they
are when they do it I just wonder like I
wonder if he's self-aware at all and
goes man I really blew that [ __ ] cuz
that guy was unbelieving yeah I mean
again I don't want to pour a lot of that
was just the the relationship it was it
was frayed so you got you mean you got a
guy who again and I go back to Aaron and
the things again one of the things that
he's doing that is like man he's doing
that it's over he's actually not trying
to play hero ball yeah so he is one of
the knocks on Aaron Rodgers how great he
is or any quarterback that has a superb
arms including like a guy like Patrick
mahomes they want to they just can't
help like nobody has an arm like them no
nobody can fit it in Windows when I
change the game in one in one throw and
so when you have that you want to show
it off it's like a new machine gun it's
like a new toy and so Aaron Rodgers had
always like literally leaned on that and
now this year it's like you know the
power of the channel I'm just gonna take
what I got I will say though the the
reason that I do always argue for
airiness maybe the top quarterback of
all the time is we know that he goes for
the home runs but it's touchdown
interception ratio is is 355 to 82 and
no one's even close so he's a gunslinger
that also protects the ball and you've
been with Brett Brett like I look at
Phillip Rivers right now and how he
throws it up and they intercepted he
goes yes fine it's like a pun it's a
putt no man it's the interception man
and you will never see Aaron do that no
like what I truly and I've said this
I've been on record saying this forever
if there was a quarterback that could go
through the season and not throw an
interception if they really want it to
yeah Aaron he's 17 touchdowns two
interceptions right now that's just who
he is and it's not like we see Russell
Wilson doing it yes and it's like oh my
gosh and and we see other guys doing
this like oh my this has been Aaron his
entire class here he was 25 touchdowns
two interceptions the year before 16 and
six he was hurt for nine games the year
before that 40 touchdowns seven
interceptions it's just every year give
me yeah I guess we have to wrap cuz I
know you're very busy or less stuff to
do and we have to end this like three
minutes okay bye
I hope that you get your time it was
good to meet you in person and to see
where it really stems from I can't
imagine what it's like to spend years
with somebody going to war with somebody
and then do via miscommunication and you
trying to start your second life it can
get frayed that's got to be painful
I wish relief to you on that appreciate
that I also wish relief to Aaron honor
because I hope Aaron can find a spot
where he is truly happy I hope that in
its it's never by accomplishment mm-hmm
you're never gonna receive one thing
that gives you peace of mind there's a
lot of stuff going on but I hope you
guys have that time 100% I just I just
want to be able to have that moment and
then say be able to still do what I do
talk negatively if you wish or be
critics the hardest part of Austria but
he know sent him an edible arrangement
that'll fix it just some strawberries I
just want to be able to do know Aaron
knows how I feel yeah I just I just want
him you know well he also has the right
to make you wait no that's the weirdest
[ __ ] and I get it
it's like it's a relationship it is it
is I want what I want when I want it you
know but it's like I told you I can't
change I know you can't change my wife
you have you have control over
everything in your world except other
people exactly good [ __ ] talk
like wise man uh enjoy I'm gonna I'm
gonna get a meal plan chicken breast and
broccoli and a little brown rice no
don't say it in dude I'm just got to
compete against you now oh they do that
too
do you have a catchphrase it's for Greg
Jennings I'm just be great be great
great huh me le mo le min I'll holla
holla at you later
what's your social I mean your social
now your so your handles at the official
DJ on Instagram and Greg Jennings follow
this man hallo Charlie Sloane see you a
war and sharp later this week peace
[Music]